amazingly this story has nothing to do
with porn a 21 year old Chinese man
collapsed outside of an internet cafe
after a 14-day internet gaming spree
after the paramedics rushed the man to
the hospital to treat his injuries the
man begged the doctors to quote leave
him alone in turn on the computer
because he wanted to surf the internet a
spectator at the cafe claims she saw the
young man often during his two week
bench during which he chain-smoked
hardly showered and ate almost nothing
the man known as mr. Xie claimed that he
had run away from home after becoming
hooked on online role-playing games such
as world of warcraft and he had found
confidence in this virtual world
according to government figures out of
china's 649 million internet users there
are an estimated twenty four million
internet addicts many of them teenagers
alright so this is one of my high horse
things that we're all addicted to this
thing I don't know if you guys watch
black mirror but it's a great show on
Netflix all about sort of the future and
how this thing is connecting us and how
it's changing us they've done stories
about how the internet is rewiring our
brains and our need for constant
approval and an immediate gratification
and all that is this like the next
addiction thing like I feel like in the
70s it was pills in the 80s it was coke
in the 90s maybe it was every dumb
opposing coach would I feel like it's
like slowly old school year old sorry
that's all right yeah then it was maybe
coke or something and then it was meth
and like is Internet addiction like the
next that's not a new thing though it's
been going on for you know since they
never became a thing I feel like in an
addiction is not anything anything new
yeah but you don't think these games are
adding to it like I feel like I i I'd
totally agree with you I just feel like
it's not like a new thing about this is
this is ongoing effort there are stories
like this all the time yeah what do you
think is this like coming is this type
of thing coming out more that people are
just literally living in these work I
mean that's what he was doing he was
living in a virtual world his body was
just some vessel that was to allow him
to be in this other universe yeah I mean
it's becoming it's because we're
becoming real
and technology in every sense so we
never get a break from it with every new
technological advance it just removes
one more thing that we can do
independently without technology so it's
you can't it's not like with coke and
with heroin like you nobody else not not
a lot of people around you are doing it
you know you're kind of in this little
bulb unless you have a really good exact
but here it's like everyone is doing its
around you all the time and you need it
to like get you from point A to B make
phone calls to find out information and
so it's like dangling the drug in front
of you all the time so you can't escape
it yeah it's yeah it's just gonna keep
spiraling out of control really do you
feel like we're trapped by it I totally
I'd not to be some that you do because I
am obviously there in an attic so I have
to kind of downplay it yeah um I will
say that I you know my ex like many
years ago was a world of warcraft addict
and I there were times when I was like I
wanted to choose between I wanted to say
I want you to choose between World of
Warcraft and me yeah but I couldn't
because I knew what he would choose so
um was it wasn't me okay I wasn't clear
um yeah so I mean yeah I don't know what
the solution is I feel like we're we're
too far down the rabbit hole now yeah so
I might offend me the best of it yeah so
whenever we do these stories i always
ask everybody do you try anything to get
off the grid a little bit to do that
shut down because i'll like sometimes
we'll have a couple people over for
dinner and I'll tell everybody just
let's all like put the phones away not
look at but then I noticed like we could
go two hours without the phones and
everyone's present and actually looking
at each other and like having real
meaningful conversation but the second
one person does it everyone gets like
the clearance and then everyone's like
like do you do anything to do the
shutdown oh one hundred percent I mean
we'll have my wife and I do no phone
dinners all the time you know it's like
a rule I've left the country before and
walked across and the entire country of
Spain without my phone just to get away
just to disconnect you know it's nice to
do that you realize like after you go
through that detox period of feeling
like you know you are missing something
or knee that you realize you're so much
more self-aware I mean you're enjoying
your surroundings more you're open to
experiences and new relationships and
ideas
it's it's crazy how much this actually
even though we think it expands our
world it really stifles our minds yes
alright so as a confess I'm doing addict
Ryu first thing the morning you wake up
do you immediately go to your phone
before your mother used to be honestly I
i well I mean this is some this sounds
still bad ball I'll get to work first I
like drive to work and then check my
phone which is actually you know all
right but I mean do I go a whole day
without it now I couldn't do that but
one day to time one day at a time all
right there you go one day at a time
anyway how addicted to this stuff are
you you guys know I talk about this all
time I think and I suffer from it too so
I'm not being holier than now but I do
try to shut down every now and again let
us know your thoughts in the comments
right now